yeah and uh Prague we saw that final
game that you did win with white uh you
arrived slightly late uh a question from
the chat from one TX
chn1c uh can you explain why you were
late was it just uh the nerves of the
occasion
no it was not enough I mean I uh I
thought it was saying five minutes on
the on the clock and I thought okay I'll
just uh used to the restroom and I went
um
and I don't maybe it was not five
minutes because I don't think I took so
long but it's just to come back uh I
kind of forgot that I have to run for
the game and yeah I was just
uh you know washing my face and so on so
it took time and yeah I lost 30 seconds
there but okay I kind of recovered from
that and uh when I managed to equal
the time I was quite happy and also I
think uh the most were flowing for me um
after this after i1 D5 uh it was kind of
very
uh yeah very clinical I would say
yeah you seem very calm despite arriving
late for the game were you aware of the
opening was it on your mind that the
stakes were so high potentially a spot
in the candidates uh stick as well
yeah somehow I was not really thinking
about the sport and candidates
yeah now it's of course
I guess it's likely that
um
there should be a spot but
before the match I didn't really think
about that I was just trying to
play um
I was just yeah trying to be confident
and try to play my best
I mean there was a moment we were
shocked with David that you came late
for that decisive game then you removed
your jacket you shadowed the pieces for
the composure please tell us how did you
do that
wait did I in general but I don't
remember but uh no I think I played
Knight F3 immediately you know
yeah
you remove your jacket
yeah okay it was not very comfortable
wearing jacket in a Blitz game so I
tried to remove it
um yeah nothing
um
yeah I was definitely upset with uh with
losing in 30 seconds because okay in the
previous game I just got down to seconds
I panicked and basically uh lost the
game and yeah to lose 30 seconds
um yeah without doing anything is
was upsetting but okay I managed to
recover